foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
breakout session on Innovations for
securing your workload with Google Cloud
Next Generation followers
my name is Tracy
today I will be delivering the session
together with two of my colleagues Megan
and Susan and our customer speaker
Richard from McKesson
I hope the message will be bringing to
you in the next 45 minutes it's going to
be an exciting ending to your first day
and next
in today's session we'll introduce the
cloud NG firewall Megan and I are going
to give you the product details from a
PM perspective that Richard will share
his perspective as a customer based on
his experience with the product
then susha will be joining us to discuss
how the open architecture offered by the
cloud NG firework is going to allow you
to easily insert a third-party file
price of your choice into the system
and in the end we'll leave time to
answer your questions
okay let's get started
here on the screen you see a charge
showing you growing trend of Cyber
attack and how quickly an attack can
penetrate once it gets into your
environment
this is probably not the first time you
see a chart like this
and yes today I'm going to remind you
again the danger is still out there
by moving your workload into the public
Cloud all this threads are not going to
subtly go away in fact in certain cases
the lateral movement of the stretch can
get even faster
therefore you need effective tool to
protect yourself
while Cloud presents some unique
challenges for security it also give us
a unique opportunity to rethink the
problem of network security and redesign
the system that can best protect you in
this new era and that is what we are
going to share with you today
you better serve our customer we first
listen to them
here are some of the top asks we have
been hearing from them over the years
when it comes to their need for network
security in the cloud
first they need the best threat and
vulnerability protection they can get to
protect them against the attack coming
from all different directions
then they need simplicity
they won't fully manage service that
auto scales they want the firewall rule
that are easy to configure and easy to
maintain over time
they also need both Broad and deep
control into every workload they put
into the cloud
and when bad things happen they want to
be able to take actions quickly to
control the damage
those are the asks that we keep in mind
when we design and implement
the cloud NG firewall
in the past two years
with this product we hope to give you a
brand new way in applying network
security control to the dynamic workload
in the cloud environment
the product comes with the Three core
pillars Advanced thread protection
simple fast and scalable and a unique
set of capabilities to help you govern
the network security posture
now let's take a look at them one by one
Advanced threat protection is always one
of the first things customers ask of us
when they put their business critical
assets into our hands to host for them
to satisfy their needs we chose to
partner with the market leader
we partner closely with the Palo Alto
networks to integrate their Market
leading threat prevention engine deep
into our system
the engine is powered by powerful ml
technology as well as massive data and
insights that they collect across the
global deployment base
we combine this with the threat
intelligence we get from mending and
other groups of Google and get a threat
prevention engine that is powerful
enough that we can protect our customer
with strong confidence
now we need to put this powerful engine
into action for that they need
Simplicity scalability and performance
and that is where our fully distributed
firewall architecture comes into play
traditionally when you deploy firework
you put the firewall appliances
you configure routing policy to send
your traffic to those appliances then
you configure the rules in the
appliances to inspect the traffic that
you send through them
in Google Cloud we took a different
approach
we adopted a fully distributed file
architecture and we built our firewall
directly into our software defined
Network and we plant the federal
inspection point right next to every VM
interface
with such architecture we can make sure
the security always follow the workload
and we allow our user to turn on the
security
across the entire cloud with zero
routing changes
this firewall fabric provides a full
protection for all workload that you
bring onto Google Cloud
no matter is running over GCE instance
or gke notes it works for traffic in no
different directions Ingress egress
north south and east west
we integrate this with the IEM govern
tag to give our customer a very reliable
mechanism for micro segmentation and
give them extremely granular control
with the system our customer can
literally turn on any firework control
between any two directly connected
interface in Google Cloud
including Advanced threat prevention
that is two interfaces across two period
Network within the same VPC Network or
even within the same subnet
the fully distributed data plan
automatically skills with the dynamic
workload you bring into the cloud
and the instance
will be protected with a fast inspection
and the engine introduced minimum
latency during the inspection
built on top of
this massive firework fabric
it's a unified firewall policy that's
used to govern every workload and their
security policies
because the security deposites is
enforced out of the routing fabric
therefore those policies can be
independently audited and insured
without worrying about any security
drift by accidental routing or network
configuration changes
every policy deployed will provide the
control for all the workloads in its
scope that scope could be an org a
folder or a network that include both
existing workload and new workload
that's deployed whenever there's a new
workload that is deployed in the cloud
the system will make sure to deploy the
relevant rules into the workload and get
that into action before
you will even allow the workload to send
or receive the first packet
and if our customers have the firewall
login turned on we'll also give them a
mail-based recommendation to help them
configure and maintain a strict rule set
over time
since the policy can be deployed at the
different layers of the gcp resource
hierarchy starting from the org followed
by folder and then go to the VPC Network
the policy enforcement order also
follows this top-down order
this type of mechanism makes sure
whatever the policy you configure and
deploy at the organization level can
never be violated by accidental policy
change at the lower level
of the hierarchy such as the project
unless you explicitly ground an
exception for them
well we give you all the mechanism to
help you maintain and control your
firewall configuration we understand
since you happen when there's baddings
that happening you need to take action
and that's where the tag-based rule
comes into the picture
with a tag based rule you can
pre-program a set of reaction functions
through those rules and when the bad
incidence happens
all you need to do is to apply the
special tag into the infected system so
all the pre-pro programmed reactions
were getting to the place and help you
control the damage
all right I hope you get excited enough
and I'll pass it over to Megan to give
you further informations on this new
product
Megan
thank you so much Tracy as Tracy
mentioned cloud ngfw is built with Palo
Alto networks Technologies
many of you are already familiar with
Palo Alto Network's threat prevention
Technologies let's see why it matters
that we built this product using Palo
Alto Network's prevention engine
Palo Alto networks threat prevention
engine is processing more than 15
trillion transactions per day which are
coming from all of the firewalls and
endpoints that they have deployed across
their huge customer base
on top of that they have more than 200
threat researchers who are going through
each of these threads and digging deeper
and making sure they have a good
understanding of threat landscape and
releasing ongoing updates
to protect the customers
the result of this is more than 4.3
million updates every day to make sure
customers are protected against the
latest zero day attacks
let's take log4j as an example then
log4j incident happened many Enterprises
were impacted
the ideal solution to address log 4G
would have been upgrading all the
software internally however that would
have been a super lengthy process
and that's where the importance of
having a security vendor such as Palo
Alto networks becomes apparent because
Palo Alto networks was quick in
releasing an update to make sure they
identify any kind of exploit sessions
that we're trying to take advantage of
log4j vulnerability
having talked about
log4j and vulnerabilities and exploits
let's take a look at what are the
different types of attacks that cloud
ngfw can protect you against
the first type of attacks is
vulnerabilities and exploits the second
type is threats and the last one is
command and control attacks when you're
talking about vulnerabilities and
exploits we are talking about things
like buffer overflows
when we think about threat prevention
they're talking about making sure we
have protection against virus or spiral
as well as known or unknown malver
and when you're talking about command
and control attacks many of you are
familiar with this category which is
super important is making sure we flag
any kind of inbox inbound or outbound
connection to malicious domains as well
as inspecting the payload to make sure
there is no command and control
communication happening
oh
now what we did since security efficacy
is super important for us and was the
first and highest priority for us when
we were releasing Cloud ngfw what we did
was making a comparison between our
products and other Cloud firewalls out
there to see how we are performing in
terms of security efficacy
and as you can see here we were more
efficient in blocking any kind of
critical or medium attacks or high
attacks
yeah compared to all the other of two
other Cloud vendors out there
um so you can see this is very important
because you want to make sure when you
buy a cloud firewall it comes with an
out of the box rule set which is
protecting you against all these kind of
attacks from day one
now let's talk about other
differentiators here Tracy already
talked about Simplicity and performance
now let's take a deeper look so what you
see on the left side is a traditional
firewall deployment and on the right
side
is a cloud ngfw deployment model we are
provided providing to you so there are
three main important things that you can
notice with the firewall deployment
first it's where the firewall is
deployed the second one is how you are
defining the traffic that is routed to
the to the firewall and the last one is
making sure that
um this where this security controls are
enforced is it that perimeter is it
close to the workload and when do you
look at this picture you can see that
basically with the new with the
traditional firewall you had the
perimeter base I Appliance or virtual
virtual VM that you're deploying at the
perimeter and you have to Route all the
traffic from your workloads to this
firewall to and you need sometimes you
need to make architectural changes for
this
and all of the enforcement is only
happening at the perimeter where the
firewall is deployed however let's
compare it with Cloud ngfw that we're
talking about today with Cloud ngfw as
Tracy talked about
we have to distributed stateful firewall
which is getting deployed as close to
the workload as possible it's right at
the VM interface level and what it
brings you as a customer is ability to
inspect the traffic whether it's east
west or north north South traffic as
well as being able to deploy this
firewall without any kind of
architecture changes or routing to be
able to send the traffic to this
firewall we have had this Cloud firewall
which provided you with layer 3 and 4
inspection in this distributed fashion
for a long time but now we're taking
this one step further by introducing
layer 7 inspection capabilities on top
of the same architecture this is again
another differentiator for us which is
rather than providing you another
different rule base for layer 7
inspection we have built the layer 7
inspection on top of the same
distributed firewall which means we are
enabling you to do the inspection as
close to the workload as possible
how we do this is using a new technology
called packet intercept which is part of
the Google Cloud's Andromeda
software-defined networking
enables us to have these firewall
endpoints located in the same Zone as
your workload being able to be like just
like a bump in the wire like routing the
traffic close to the workload to the
firewall endpoint inspecting the traffic
using the Palo Alto networks firewall
which is running under the hood and then
enforcing the policy you set and
continuing with their flow
let's talk about what value this brings
to you so um
Tracy touched on this topic already so
one of the biggest values of this
architecture and this partnership with
Palo Alto networks is the operational
Simplicity we already talked about
security efficacy now operational
Simplicity has been top of mind for many
of our customers with the traditional
approach you have perimeter rules and
sometimes you have workload rules as
well but they're only for layer 3 and 4.
and anytime there is any change in your
infrastructure when you have new
workloads for example you have to have
this manual process making sure your
policies are up to date or just your
posture is secure and is reflecting the
same infrastructure workloads that you
have
if there is an incident happening it
might be super slow to go brute force
and making sure the policy is applied
everywhere versus the new model with
Cloud ngfw we are providing you with a
single policy which is basically this
hierarchical policy Tracy talked about
combining workload and perimeter
bringing both layer 3 and 4 all of them
all next to the workload and making sure
the policy is following the workload
using the IAM tags enabling you to write
these policies and it simplifies your
incident response process as well so if
there is any incident rather than that
manual process policy is going to
automatically be applied to all of your
workloads that you're defining with that
policy
Let's uh talk about Cloud ngfw I will
close my section by wrapping it up
saying what are the different tiers when
we say cloud ngfw cloud ngfw is consists
of three main tiers Essentials standard
and plus
Cloud firewall stands Essentials has
been there for a long time you're
probably using it which is covering L3
and 4 inspection we recently launched
Cloud firewall standard which is adding
threat intelligence fqdn objects and and
geolocation objects and with this
presentation I was telling you about
Cloud firewall plus which is basically
providing you with layer 7 inspections
across TLS and non-tillas traffic
powered by Palo Alto Network threat
prevention Technologies we are going to
Rebrand Cloud firewall to Cloud ngfw
next year
I wrap up my talk and I would like to
invite Richard one of our dear customers
to walk you through his journey with
Cloud firewall Richard
foreign
hi everyone my name is Richard Prasad
I'm a network security architect with
cover my meds I covered my meds as a
business unit of McKesson we are in the
healthcare industry
as a network security architect I design
engineer and implement the network and
network security components that protect
our environments and workloads
today I would like to talk about network
security architecture in the cloud and
how Google's firewall products helps us
secure our workloads and environments
so what we have here is a typical VPC or
I'm sorry a typical Hub and spoke Design
This is modified in the sense that I do
have a separate inbound Hub that I will
explain in a bit in more detail
a large driver of this design came from
Operational Support perspective
this needs to be easy
to understand and to support
and this design
meets all of those requirements
this design uses shared vpcs
host and service projects
at the center is the transit hub
this is where all of our networking and
network security takes place this
includes Cloud routers
interconnects vpns and our Transit
firewalls
all of the spokes in this design
appeared to this Transit hub
with the exception of the sandboxes
the VPC spokes are essentially an
application or application group
the spokes appeared as I mentioned
earlier to the transit hub
everything traverses through this
Transit hub
so let's say we have an application in
spoke a that wants to talk to another
application in Spoke B
that is going to Traverse that Transit
hub
if spoke B needs to get out to the
Internet it's going to go through that
Transit hub
consequently if on-premise needs to talk
to one of the spokes it's going to
Traverse that Transit Hub and vice versa
if a Spoke needs to talk to on-premise
um
for the inbound part
we decided to split our inbound traffic
so that is where the modified portion of
Hub and spoke come in
if a customer
and the internet internet-based customer
needs to access an application in a
Spoke they're going to come through the
internet come through this inbound Hub
the inbound Hub has its own networking
and network security stack and then go
into the application spoke and then if
that application spoke needs to reach
further inbound it'll go through that
transits hub
the not all spokes are going to be
internet accessible not all of them will
need inbound access so those that do not
need that access will not be peered to
that inbound hub
the sandboxes are basically a tech
playground
where you can try new ideas and new
technologies
those sandboxes do not have any
production data
do not have any non-prod data
and they're not connected to the dev
environments or the production
environments at all they're completely
isolated
now
how do we secure this
well the first part is with the classic
Google firewalls these are great they're
fast they're simple
they're easy to maintain
but a huge part of network security is
visibility
and we need that layer 7 visibility
so what we have decided to do in this
design
is to deploy
VM based Palo Alto Auto scaling firewall
appliances
because the hubs are Central to
everything we've decided to put them in
that Center transits Hub as well as the
inbound hub
these next-gen firewalls are at the core
of our design
so being that these are Palo alto's we
are now able to achieve top of class
application visibility
the transit firewalls for both the
inbound and the Hub uh since they are VM
appliances integrate directly with
panorama
so managing them is a very familiar feel
yeah
while I current design Works fairly well
we do have a few challenges
first we have multiple layers of
firewall rules that we have to manage
we've got the gcp firewall rules
and we also have Palo Alto firewall
rules
there is routing and network maintenance
that has to happen
every time we add a VPC
or a subnet we need to manually add
static routes
to the route tables on the Palo Alto
appliances
our Auto scaling design for the Palo
alto's
requires the use of source netting or
snats
this adds a layer of complexity when
we're trying to troubleshoot
we also have to write and maintain
separate terraform code
for the Palo Alto deployments as well as
the cloud native firewall rules
then there is also the maintenance of
the VM Palo Altos
code upgrades
life cycle maintenance licensing
sizing requirements cost
as well as Auto scale monitoring and
maintenance
with the addition of firewall plus to
the product catalog we are now able to
maintain our efficacy
with Cloud native firewalling and the
power the power of the Palo Alto threat
injured behind it we now have the same
or better level of protection as with
the VM Palo Altos
we can maintain our health care
Regulatory Compliance and increase our
overall security posture by introducing
less complications
we also have easier TLS implementation
which also means better visibility
the distributed data plane will also let
allow for Less firewalls overall without
losing performance or resiliency
we can achieve East-West and north-south
protection without multiple sets of
firewalls
it also increases the Simplicity of the
design and the overall maintenance
with firewall plus there are no routing
changes
there's no more snaps to worry about we
have simplified terraform coding and
also faster deployment times
now I'd like to talk a little bit about
a conceptual
next version design using firewall Plus
now this is a similar Hub and spoke
design
the difference here is I can collapse
this down into one VPC and multiple
subnets
because of the design Simplicity and the
cloud native integration
it's even easier for our operations team
to understand and maintain
I have uh it's easier to implement micro
segmentation as well
the distributed data plane will increase
the overall performance of our
environments
and being powered by Palo Alto threat
engines we can actually increase our
layer 7 visibility and increase the
efficiency of our design
overall firewall plus is an amazing and
Powerful addition to the Google product
line
and will definitely help secure your
workloads in a simpler and more
efficient way
I'd like to now hand the presentation
over to our next presenter sushant
[Applause]
thanks return
we at Google Cloud are all about meeting
customers where they are we understand
that not every one of your network
security needs can be met with our first
party native Solutions
we know that some of you have a
preference towards using your trusted
vendor solutions to protect your Google
Cloud workloads so in the next few
slides I'm going to provide a sneak
preview into the things that we are
working on to make it easy for you to
deploy and consume your choice of
third-party Network Security Solutions
it's easier to understand why we are
doing certain things the way we are
doing if you understand the core
differentiators we are bringing to the
table and more importantly understand
what these differentiators mean to you
right
so let me start with listing out the top
three core differentiators in our
approach to enabling third-party network
security insertion on Google Cloud
one we are going to provide you a
consistent experience regardless of
whether you choose to use native network
security solution or your choice of
third-party network security solution
two
we are going to enable you to express
your network security intent as a policy
rather than as a network rules or
routing rules and three
we are going to ensure that the
deployment and operation of third-party
appliances is as simple as consuming as
a service experience
now let me get into the details of why
each of these differentiators is
relevant for you
so let's start with Cloud native
experience
we had Cloud firewall that provided
layer 3 and layer 4 protections
and Cloud firewall comes with a lot of
feature-rich capabilities such as
hierarchical policy support IEM backed
security tax
firewall insights and many more right so
when we wanted to introduce our native
next gen firewall solution we extended
the cloud firewall policy language to
enable you to express your intent of
what traffic needs to go for advanced
security inspections so when it came
time to introduce third party insertion
we retain the same policy constructs and
the language so that you are able to
consistently Express the intent of which
of your traffic needs to be delivered to
your deployed setup third party
firewalls for advanced deep packet
inspection
what this means is all the feature
capabilities of cloud firewall are
enabled to you regardless of whether you
choose to use first party Solutions or
the third party solution
this also means going through Regulatory
and compliance hardits becomes a whole
lot simpler
when it comes time for your next network
security audit there are only two
details you need to share with your
auditors one obviously is the security
policy that you implemented on your
third party firewalls and two
Cloud firewall rules which gives your
Auditors a comprehensive picture of
which of your traffic is being protected
by layer 3 and layer 4 rules and which
of your application traffic is being
sent to the your deployed set of
third-party firewalls for advanced
repacket inspection
staying on the theme of inheriting the
rich feature capabilities of cloud
firewall
the native integration with firewall
insights allows you to get
recommendations on how you can optimize
your traffic selection rules to save on
cost and to improve your network
security posture
coming to the second differentiator the
ability to express your network intent
as a policy rather than networking rules
allows you to seamlessly insert
third-party next-gen firewalls into your
existing Brownfield application
deployments without going through any
network re-architecture or
reconfiguration
the intent that you express is enforced
at the workload what this means is even
if this workload moves to a different
PPC different project or if this
workload spins down and comes back up at
a later point in time
you can be rest assured that the policy
will always follow the workload
lastly we are working with our next-gen
firewall partners to allow you to
implement micro segmentation into your
cloud workloads
the intent that you express in the cloud
firewall rules is automatically shared
with the with your deployed set of
firewall appliances so that you don't
have to express the intent in multiple
places the only additional detail that
you have to express on the firewalls is
what Security Services you want to
enforce on your selected traffic
so far I've covered how we made it easy
for you to select what traffic needs
Advanced inspection but then we also
understand that deploying these firewall
appliances at scale is often challenging
so we went one step further
we are working on this network service
integration manager that will provide
you guided workflows to discover deploy
and operate third-party network security
appliances
the approach we have taken is we will
provide you a sas-like consumption
experience while you retain the full
control over the life cycle of the
appliances what this means is you get to
decide which version of software you
want to run on these firewalls what
securities or signature updates that you
want to install on them when you want to
upgrade them or downgrade them
and all of this would be enabled through
Easy Button approach
most importantly
you will now have a single dashboard
View
to manage and monitor all your
third-party deployments
before I close out I want to emphasize
that Innovations like this are not built
in isolation
we are very grateful to our next-gen
firewall Partners Cisco 49 checkpoint
and Palo Alto networks Who provided
valuable guidance feedback and input to
make sure that we are building the most
easy to consume experience when it comes
to network security on Google Cloud
[Music]
foreign